there is no such thing as a global
anthem a global currency or a global
flag this is the United States of
America that I'm representing I'm not
representing the globe I'm representing
your country Donald Trump has promised
to make America great again by putting
America first so we was speaking at the
Conservative Political Action Conference
or CPAC it's got to be said that he's no
small government conservative in fact
his speech made clear that he represents
the worst tendencies of conservative
Republicans and Liberal Democrats to
limit our freedoms in the name of
supposedly serving the greater good
Trump is an economic protectionist and
interventionist who wants to promote
what he perceives our our values by
building a wall to keep out immigrants
charging tariffs on imports badgering US
companies to stay here in making
pipelines with only American steel all
of that will only make everything cost
more while reducing employment the GOP
will be from now on the party also of
the American worker he talks about
bringing back manufacturing jobs but
they peaked as a percentage of the
workforce in 1943 and are never coming
back for a very good reason thanks to
technological innovation manufacturing
output has doubled since the 1980s but
with one-third fewer workers shutting
down free trade or playing CEO and chief
is not going to change that at the heart
of trumps confusion is his belief that
putting America first means keeping the
world at a distance but you can be a
citizen of America and a citizen of the
world in fact if you believe in
political economic and cultural freedom
you must always hold such dual
citizenship there's no more basic
freedom than the right to live where you
want and buy what you want that's not
anti America that is America in
different ways over the years
Republicans and Democrats have tried to
control where we can live who we can
marry what we can eat drink and smoke
and so much more Trump represents not a
release from such thinking but a shotgun
marriage of that worst impulse in each
party we're going to win we're going to
win big folks we're going to start
winning again believe me
we're going to win where Liberty dwells
there is my country Ben Franklin is said
to have written in putting America first
Donald Trump will succeed only in
leaving even more of us truly homeless
[Music]
you